just labour is not going to get you
somewhere right kind of action the right
timing right place all this is important
isn't it the events around you may not
be determined by you but how your
experience of life is on this planet is
100% determined by you believe me you're
not going to be here forever
I'll bless you with a long life but
you're going to fall that one day if
you're beginning to think that what
you're doing is very important you need
to take a holiday you cannot fight or
you cannot overcome that which does not
exist we have fixed too many things on
the outside if you fix anymore there
won't be a planet left he's an Indian
yogi mystic philanthropist and author he
founded a nonprofit organization which
offers yoga programs around the world he
also found a project green hand a
grassroots ecological initiative in
India he said guru and here's my take on
his top ten rules for success my
personal favourite clip is number seven
some curious to figure out which one you
guys like the best effort has to be
incisive in the sense it should be
focused calibrated she believed you make
effort it's foolish effort isn't it just
labour is not going to get you somewhere
right kind of action the right timing
right place all this is important isn't
it so for all these things to happen you
need perception and intelligence so
that's all you must do in your life
constantly looking for ways to enhance
your perception and your intelligence
the rest will anyway happen this is one
thing that unfortunately Humanity is not
doing they're trying to become capable
of something do not try to become
capable of something just enhance your
perception and intelligence can you see
me right now all of you
can you see me just point out where I am
use your hands and point out can you see
me are you got it wrong you know I am a
mystic you're getting it completely
wrong now this light is falling upon me
reflecting going through your lenses
inverted image in your retina you know
the whole story right where do you see
me right now within yourself where do
you hear me right now within yourself
where have you seen the whole world
within yourself have you ever
experienced anything outside of yourself
everything that ever happened to you
darkness and light happened within you
pain and pleasure happened within you
joy and misery happen within you have
you ever experienced anything outside of
yourself no so what I am asking you is
what happens within you who should
determine how it should happen what
happens within you who should determine
how this should happen somebody else
definitely you should determine what
should happen within this isn't it so if
you determine what's happening within
this your whole experience of life will
be determined by you nobody else but you
isn't it the events around you may not
be determined by you but how your
experience of life is on this planet is
100% determined by you if you take
charge of this if you leave it loose
just about anybody will determine it
they will not consciously they also like
you by accident if you if you just
observe
if everybody makes an little effort
everybody take a little time for this
piece of life okay
not for your family not for your carrier
not for something else something else
just for this piece of life give it
little time because this is the most
important piece of life in your life
isn't it yes or no yeah even if you're
in love with somebody still this is the
most important piece of life isn't it so
pay some attention to this how does it
happen why have you taken it for granted
believe me you're not going to be here
forever I'll bless you with a long life
but you're going to fall dead one day
yes or no yes so do not take this for
granted if you wake up in the morning
tomorrow if you wake up in the morning
[Music]
now this is not my wish but I want you
to know of all the people who go to bed
tonight over a million people will not
wake up tomorrow morning and tomorrow if
you and we wake up tomorrow morning is
it not a fantastic thing a million
people did not wake up you woke up is it
not a great thing just look at the
ceiling and smile you are still awake
you still there and for many many
millions of people somebody who is dear
to them did not wake up so just check
those five six people around you they
all woke up wow it's a fantastic day you
woke up and everybody who matters to you
around you woke up is it not fantastic
day you don't think so yes
you don't seem to think shop see because
the problem is just this you are living
with an idea that you are immortal when
I say you're immortal
you're not actually thinking you're
immortal but you are not conscious of
your morali mortality if you are not
conscious of your mortality somewhere
you think you're immortal isn't it how
many moments in a day are you conscious
that you're mortal
if you were conscious would you have
time to crib would you have time to
fight with somebody would you have time
to do some rubbish with your life if you
knew if you are conscious that you're
mortal you would do nothing other than
what is absolutely needed for you and
everybody around you this one thing if
you do if you just remind yourself you
don't think this is a negative thing
death is not a negative thing it's the
only thing which is added value to your
life if you are here forever you would
be unbearable yes yes you won't be glad
everybody dies one day if you just
become conscious of this one thing that
always you're conscious that I'm mortal
you don't have to think I will die today
we don't intend we want to live as far
as possible
just you know one day I will die if you
just conscious of this one thing you
will naturally become spiritual every
day every moment if you remind yourself
this is a brief life and motto one day I
will end just do this for two days and
see you will become something truly
fantastic within yourself just this is
all and it's simply beautiful that's all
that's needed if you want to know the
value of life just know that it's a
brief happening just loosen up your life
a little bit laugh a little more involve
yourself with people around you do
things that you think is not so
important don't do things which are very
important do simple things very
important you do simple things very
important things you're doing in your
life you will become dead serious
you know Bertrand Russell and Englishman
Bertrand Russell said if you're
beginning to think that what you are
doing is very important you need to take
a holiday
so holiday does not mean coming to India
holiday is every day in those 24 hours
you must take a holiday from your
seriousness from yourself seriousness
has come essentially because of your
self-importance you hold yourself as an
important person I want you to see you
are like a speck of dust in this
existence tomorrow morning if you
disappear for sure in India nobody will
miss you even down under they won't
bother much you know a handful of people
they will also forget soon enough you
nature o nature the roof you're gone and
nothing will happen in this world
everything will happen wonderfully well
even if you're not there every human
being should be aware of this every
moment of his life it does not matter
what the whole world says about you it
does not matter how significant a work
you're doing
you must understand that tomorrow
morning the world will go on fine
without you whoever you may be
isn't it so if you constantly remind
yourself of this you'll have no reason
to be serious definitely not dead and
don't be dead now a time will come it's
time to be alive to create fear you have
to use excessive imagination to not be
in fear you don't have to do anything
real is happening because of excessive
imagination things that have not
happened you're creating
what may happen in your mind happens in
thousand different formats and most
probably it never happens the things
that you feared take hundred things that
you have feared probably 99 of them
never happened isn't it yes so you're
here your fear is always about that
which does not exist you cannot fight or
you cannot overcome that which does not
exist we can overcome something with
that exists you cannot overcome that
which does not exist you just have to
give up that effort enjoy the fear after
all it's your making you like horror
movies yes
I mean you're saying no but you you're
producing them just they're not making
money it's all fear means you're
producing horror movies in your mind
nobody else is willing to watch that's
bad for the producer but you're
producing them so you produce something
else but it's a comedy a love story
just pens filler try and see today just
sit down
but use a love story a suspense thriller
a comedy fire five minutes more movies
you make in your mind really start using
your mind differently it is gotten into
your pattern just gotten into your
pattern of just creating order movies
all the time you have watched enough
horror movies the boring create
something else even it's not that if you
produce these movies those things will
happen in your life still they may not
happen at least you enjoy the movie in
reality it may not happen so what
at least you enjoy what's happening in
your mind if you cannot enjoy what's
happening in the world isn't it that
much privilege every human being
deserves isn't it so even though the
world is not kind to him at least his
own mind should be kind to him should
produce some nice movies we are
completely committed to one dimension of
our intelligence which we call as the
intellect which is just the thought
process thought can only happen with the
data that you have gathered through five
senses which is very limited one thing
another thing is the nature of data that
the senses gathered are only useful for
survival process the very nature of how
you see things how you hear smell and
taste and touch life is only relevant
for survival process if you wanting to
know the life itself then these
instruments of perception are no good
even what is life and darkness is a
debate between you and another creature
which sees darkness as light isn't it if
you sit within an owl and start an
argument as to which is light and which
is darkness it's an endless argument but
who do you think is right hello if
you're saying both you're either in the
diplomatic corps or or you have a
successful marriage
[Applause]
you'll learn to say both both but which
is the truth what I see is the truth or
what the owl sees is the truth that's
not the point it is just that nature is
opened up our sense perception as it is
necessary for our survival accordingly
it is opened up sense perceptions for
different creatures as it is necessary
for their survival but if survival is
all you're seeking this is good enough
the five senses but once you have come
as a human being
somehow survival is not good enough if
your stomach is empty there's only one
issue about food but once the stomach
becomes full you have a hundred issues
going on so the nature of the human
being is such no matter what you do you
want to be something more than what you
are right now
and if that's something more happens
something more something or it's an
endless pursuit so somewhere a human
being is seeking a limitless expansion
but trying to do it with physical means
the very nature of physicality is a
defined boundary if there is no defined
boundary there is no possibility of
physical happening in the universe but
now a human being is longing for the
boundless that too in installments and
through physical means through the
boundary you're trying to become
boundless the desire is fantastic the
method is hopeless because the moment
you identify yourself with something
your intellects work is just to protect
that identity if you whatever the
identities of nation or family or gender
or race religion whatever the moment you
identify yourself with something your
intellect will only function around that
to protect that so it is a certain type
of prejudice the moment you are
identified so the only thing I did with
my life is I never
identified myself with anything and life
just exploded within me in ways that
thought seems so puny that I do not
indulge in thought most of the time
pleasantness is the choice isn't it so
why is it so much unpleasantness is
happening in human experience because we
never took charge of the inner dimension
we believe by fixing the outside
everything is going to be okay in the
last hundred hundred fifty years with
the advent of science and modern
technology we have fixed too many things
on the outside if you fix anymore there
won't be a planet left
yes definitely this has brought much
convenience and comfort to our lives in
every way we are the most comfortable
generation ever you agree with me I know
you have series of complaints about how
things are not okay but we are the most
comfortable generation ever before on
this planet isn't it so but we cannot
say we are the most joyful generation on
the planet we are the most loving
generation on the planet we are the most
blissed-out generations our plant
definitely not we are complaining
complaining like crazy about everything
like never before this is because we fix
the outside comfort and convenience has
happened well-being has not happened if
your interior tea was handled by you
consciously you would definitely keep
this in a blissful State so he is bliss
the goal of life no bliss is a necessary
condition for life to flower to its full
potential otherwise it will remain
constrained you're paying too much
attention to everything around you not
enough attention to this farm but the
quality of your life is essentially
determined by how you carry this one so
this moment what kind of clothes you're
wearing what kind of card you popped out
what kind of home you live in does not
determine the quality of your life
this moment how joyful are you feeling
within yourself determines the quality
of your life isn't it so nothing has
been done about it you think it'll
happen in consequence and you're setting
impossible goals for your happiness if I
have to be happy my wife should be like
this my husband should be like that my
children should be like this the world
should become some other way well these
are impossible conditions you're setting
for your happiness and peacefulness now
that you have compromised yourself to
peace why I'm saying compromise yourself
to pc's because a lot of people have
given up aspirations for being ecstatic
or blissful if I'm just peaceful it's
enough even the so-called spiritual
leaders are going about him saying peace
is the highest goal in your life peace
is not the highest goal in your life if
you want to enjoy your lunch today
you must be peaceful yes or if you're
not even peaceful there is nothing in
your life that you can do in a
worthwhile way to be peaceful
essentially means this that you're not
messing your mind to be peaceful means
that your system is at ease you know how
to conduct your mind you know how to
conduct your emotions your body and your
energies you are peaceful it is not a
rocket technology it is the most basic
thing you have a dog at home you give
him his food he sits peacefully maybe
not ecstatic but please film any times
they're ecstatic also yes if your dog is
able to sit pee so he doesn't have to
run my industry that's not the point
he's got his own stuff going
[Music]
see it has nothing to do with the
external activity that you're doing it's
got something to do with the internal
systems as to how they're functioning
essentially it means he that neither
your body now your mind or your
chemistry nor emotions nor energy are
taking instructions from you that doing
their own thing once your machine is not
in your control being post peaceful is
impossible I will tell you you get into
your car
and now you go there and you want to
turn this way you do this to the
steering it goes this way
can you peacefully drive this car can
you no anxiety is natural isn't it this
is what has happened to your vehicle
it's out of control you never done
anything to find out where the steering
wheel is first of all this is not that
simple as a car this is a super super
computer now the problem is most people
have not even bothered to find the
keyboard they think if they do this
somehow it will work if you make when
you are given such a highly
sophisticated machine if you do not
conduct it properly it will cause many
problems to you by accident it's working
I want you to know this this is made
this way if you hold your hands like
this it will breathe one way if you just
turn it around the very way you breathe
the breathing pattern itself changes in
your lungs you can try it if you want
when you have the time this way this way
I'm saying everything that you do
fundamental changes are happening in
this machine because it's such a
sophisticated machine it's more than a
touchscreen if you just wish it it will
happen when you have such a sensitive
and sophisticated machine and you are
operating like a blacksmith then being
peaceful seems to be difficult peace is
not the highest goal in your life it is
the most fundamental requirement don't
ever set peace as the highest goal if
you do that you're lonely rest in peace
you must see to be peaceful is the first
thing in your life isn't it if you want
to do anything sensibly in your life if
you want to do conduct any situation in
your life sensibly to be peaceful and
happy is fundamental unfortunately in
many ways not just in the way that I
said now in many different ways I would
say 70% of illnesses on the planet all
kinds are self created even if you get
an infection there is a way if you keep
yourself in a certain way physically and
mentally the virus in the bacteria will
not work the same way as it works upon
somebody else if you set yourself like
this no matter what's happening anyway I
have to go and do this this and this
there's no break from that the last 29
years I have not been able to cancel one
program because I'm running temperature
I got a cold I got this I got that it
doesn't matter what's happening what you
have to do you anyway have to do you
can't turn back on that either out of
your commitment or you have a boss like
that one or one way or the other if it
happens then you will see you will not
at all fall sick so often because if you
have temperature you still have to go if
it's summer you still go right now a lot
of people don't go it's a little hot
outside they don't go and work little
cold outside they don't go and work a
little raining they won't go and work a
snowflake they will not go and work this
is just weather so for every change in
weather if you have the comfort of
cowering yourself in a blanket and lying
down once you create that your body will
learn to fall sick as often as possible
if you just keep it this way
it doesn't matter what it is anyway I
have to go and do what I have to do you
will see your body will just bounce back
as quickly as possible even if it gets
the worst kind of infections so you just
have to set the necessary conditions for
health necessary in incentives for
health both for yourself and your
children if you have them do not set
incentives for sickness I was speaking
in Nashville a few years ago I was just
telling them a joke in the joke I
referred to God as him immediately a few
ladies stood up do you believe God is a
man whoa I know where it's going I was
only telling you a joke
it doesn't matter you said him do you
believe God is a man I said I was only
telling a joke
it doesn't matter so now there is an
argument going around in certain parts
of America is God a man or a woman in
India we have no such problems we have a
man god we have a woman god we have a
cow god we have an elephant god we have
a monkey we have a snake we have flying
one is crawling once creeping one's
every kind because it's a very wise
culture we foresaw all the future
problems that may arise thank you guys
so much for watching I made this video
because more TV RN asked me to so
there's a famous entrepreneur you want
me to profile next leave it in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do this is a little bit of a different
top ten so I'm still very curious to see
which of the rules had the biggest
impact on you and why this one goes a
little bit deeper more spiritual so let
me know what you think in the comments
below thank you again so much for
watching continue to believe and I'll
see you soon